welcome back to New rockstars and the
Guardians of the Galaxy are being hunted
and no I don't mean by just those gold
Gremlins The Sovereign with Aisha trying
to Frankenstein and Adam Warlock of mass
Guardian ass destruction because what if
I told you that as of the Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special the Guardians
have yet another Sovereign Nation in the
MCU coming to tan those galactically
diverse behinds this is Rogue Theory the
show where we pitch the wildest theories
for the nerdy titles that we love my
name is Mt and going wrong with me today
is star-lord's other sister it's Whitney
van lattingham what's going on with me
hi oh my gosh yeah Star-Lord uh is
actually a hundred percent my brother
that's why we don't talk to Chris Pratt
at holidays anymore because uh you know
he's not after the Mario thing our
family kind of disowned him but oh my
God
she said Wahoo are you
um
this is why my parents don't love me
anymore and we're very excited to be
joined today by The Two Hosts from the
friends from work podcast Kyle Stoner
will and Robbie Earl what's going on
let's go thanks for having us let's go
what an honor what an honor Rogue Theory
like I'm so excited to go roll with you
guys like I understand that you guys
cover Marvel stuff and love Marvel stuff
as much as we do and they'll be kicking
off their phase five coverage in January
so be sure to check them out at the
ffwpodcast.com to just like listen to
two amazing guys just talk about Marvel
um but yes I'm so excited to talk with
you guys that's really sweet because
they're friends from work and then Mt
we're friends from work and then the
Avengers are friends from work and it's
just it's just really sweet I think it's
really it's awesome and sweet I think
this is a great crossover app
wow it's not as cold in Austin as it is
in Boston but if it were yes that would
have formed my heart yeah
thank you that was good I like that but
yeah no let's get into these wrong
theories because our first topic of
today is I have this feeling I have an
inkling that wakanda will go after the
Guardians of the Galaxy for stealing
their wakandan property Bucky's wakandan
made vibranium arm because as we saw in
uh Falcon the Winter Soldier these guys
take their vibranium extremely seriously
and um like and as we saw from what if
they have the capabilities of space
travel like the condenser it's like so
few so futuristic that um they they're
they have the abilities to go into space
um and I have this feeling that it once
they hear that what uh Bucky got messed
with nebula they're gonna be like well
uh we don't play with that [ __ ] uh Bucky
is our friend he's our brother uh we
don't [ __ ] you with the Bucky so uh we
we're doing it's outer space and um
[Laughter]
millions of I'm sorry everyone would buy
that absolutely there's no one who
wouldn't buy that
let's do it uh but no I I honestly I
think there's a real possibility I think
it'd be at least make a really great
what-if episode if uh wakanda just went
after the Guardians for this heinous act
of um uh attacking an ally wakanda and
stealing what condom property what do
you guys think about this so let's break
down the arm first of all yes impossible
switch right there's an off switch so do
we know that nebula took it forcefully
in the first place listen
don't spoil my next Theory I'm doing the
next theory on how the arm got don't
spoil it don't spoil it we're just right
now Focus wakandans will they get it
back I promise I promise we'll talk
about that [ __ ] in like 10 minutes we're
gonna talk about that how advanced do
you think their space travel is I think
that they're they I think honestly they
probably have like well Conan agents
already in space of course because like
absolutely their technology is just so
and like they were able to detect Thanos
entering orbit in uh infinity War like
instantaneously so like I feel like they
have some secret space missions because
like we've seen in One Division that
like the US just is like starting to
like Enter space because with uh with
sword it's like all right like we're
starting to do space travel and we know
that wakanda is already always future
like a super like Generations ahead so
like they've gotta have space travel
going on that's true they're they're
what Elon Musk wishes he could be so
there's no way that they haven't set up
like a secret cool Mars colony or like
another planet like they absolutely
there's absolutely a wakanda in space
it's like you know like how there's like
there's like Disneyland in Paris there's
like yeah
the wakanda space race was in like the
1860s yeah it was exactly exactly
exactly so just hanging it's like watch
the Civil War get out of here but yeah
no I I think that it'd be really really
fun to just have Rocket Raccoon just
like just go hand to hand against the
wakanda Army just like like I have oh
man so over the weekend this is super
random but I was like what is Bucky what
is Rocket Raccoon gonna do with this arm
and I was like what if in Guardians 3 he
makes like a human-sized Mech of all the
Barney parts that he's stolen dude
different colors
he steals a couple of like pieces of
pimtec just to like mix it up in there
that's true maybe he can shrink it all
and that's how he hides it for a while
yeah basically to do it exactly like
perfect like I I feel like rocket
definitely stole some big particles as
well like he's a thief
we love him you know I I do feel like
there's a reason why this could escalate
into a sort of military type conflict
because I was thinking what's the
relationship between the Guardians and
the wakandans and the first thing that
came to mind was the relationship that
rocket and nebula would have had with a
koye during the blip years but we now
know a queen is not really Affiliated
officially with the wakandan government
anymore so that might have been like a a
cooling Factor that's no longer present
so things could just heat up immediately
who knows Cherie's got stuff to prove
yeah maybe they just go for it this is
true it wasn't her position like
slightly reinstated at the end Rob I
mean she's at least working with shuri
with the new high-tech suit thingies so
she might have her own Rogue mission to
go get it herself or the technology
capable of doing it this could also be
like a little like like a you know a
conflict of interest for her because
what if shuri's like bro go get the
[ __ ] arm back and she's like no I
love rocket and he always he really did
always want that arm I can't take it
from him you know
like I said I really want to know
Bucky's standing in all this
too I lost this we're gonna talk about
it I promise you all my life
I will tell you exactly what happened
it's it's also knowing how much rocket
did want that arm it's a real shame that
when Bucky was dusted the arm was dusted
along yeah it could have been a real
silver line it was such a great
consolation prize like sorry all your
friends are dead but but here's this
that'd be so hilarious he's like he's
like oh no brood oh sweet
I think it was just everything balances
so fast fall off as he dusted you'd
think right that's funny oh man Universe
in Perfect Balance
do you guys think that if wakanda were
to um attack the Guardians that the
Guardians would be able to hold up
against like older own against the
wakandans no no there's no way you
literally no there's no way so it
depends on how many but let's look quill
first of all gave up his God Powers so
he's made he's mainly a human with uh
some guns now right so that's rookie
right yeah yeah
rocket
he's got the arm now I guess to his
Advantage but it's it's rocket yeah
that's one arm against all of wakanda
who can bring as many arms as they want
to in whatever form they want to they
can bring a whole [ __ ] Rhino to space
to take him out like all right there's
no way like the Rhinos come off the
spaceship
rhinos
drax's body is impenetrable to bullets
apparently but not vibranium Tech
probably true or rhino horns for all we
know I mean those things deadly we do
know that he would not have been able to
take the blast from Tony Stark uh in
Infinity war and oh yeah I feel like
right wakan in Tech is superior to Stark
Tech at this point I I think right so
yeah yeah they stand no chance and like
we know that Drac has a famously
sensitive nipples yeah
um
just like a news broadcast being like
this just in Drax defeated by 12 year
old boys
in gym class tell me old boy pulling
prank destroys destroys the Destroyer
like what do you think that Bucky is
going to go after nebula this is
Whitney's question now is this her time
is it a moment
but like just like what do you guys
think of the idea of like Bucky teaming
up with the wakandans to um to go
um get the the Army I think no we left
Bucky in a very different spot at the
end of Falcon Winter Soldier and I feel
like he's he's changed a little bit I
don't think he's as much about vengeance
and stuff so that's why I want to know
with the transaction there but no I
don't I don't think he's teaming up in
this I think this is a wakanda uh
revenge tour
I also feel like wakanda would be pissed
at Bucky for losing it because they'd be
like true you are some little broken
white boy who we fixed up and gifted a
billion dollar arm too and you just let
a goddamn raccoon have it as a Christmas
present right like I mean I don't know
I'm gonna be like I raised you better
than you I would be okay if I made if I
gave somebody like a really nice gift
and then they let a trash Panda take it
to space I would be like hey what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you dude we were so
nice to you I thought we were friends
like we re-gifted that arm you're so
right never again right you never regive
you never regive so cheap my God but
yeah okay so let's let's do the voting
now because like with this theory of
wakanda going after the Guardians
pursuing what kind of property do you
guys think that it is rogus bogus or
August double rogus [ __ ] I think that
already in space they're already hot on
the tail it's going it's going great
okay double Rogan
I'm August for one reason August for one
reason okay I still think the one
advantage the Guardians have here is in
the space travel side of it we haven't
seen that I know we think they're out
there but the gardens are pretty
Advanced when it comes to the space
travel stuff can they run away forever
maybe I'm August on it okay okay I'll
take the oh guess I'll take the oh it's
one bro guess what I'll go what about
you so I think I'm I think I'm gonna go
August as well so so I mean I think
you're still trending positive I'm I'm
torn yeah no I'll take I'm torn because
on the one hand
they don't need to go get the arm you
know they've obviously got plenty of
vibranium so part of me is like would
they really Marshal this for the one arm
but then on the other hand you know we
saw and what kind of forever that they
care a lot about nobody else having
vibration so maybe it is and and you
know to your point In fairness and maybe
now I'm I'm leaning towards making my my
August uh uh
see that happens sometimes because
because now I'm thinking do they is
there any vibranium out in the the rest
of the Galaxy I don't think so not that
we know of so there is on um torfa is a
vibranium planet in the comics I don't
know if that's a true true bmcu
um but yeah it is a Dusty planet from
Captain Marvel so I wouldn't be
surprised if there were vibranium
deposits there but like officially yeah
we don't know well and I because if if
there isn't and I guess you know if
wakanda doesn't doesn't know that there
is I could see them being particularly
nervous about that getting out into the
into the different civilizations where
they could maybe analyze and replicate
vibranium and then you've you know right
that's right a whole mess on your hands
yeah exactly that's a really good point
so are you switching to rogus or not
yeah are we August or rogus yeah yeah
I'm I'm uh I'm rogus now
um
but no I really do like this idea of
like wakanda just wanting to just like
keep their most valuable resource away
from now that like you know Earth has
Intergalactic energy so like they would
want to grab that be like all right if
you they didn't get our they didn't get
to analyze our secret weapon I've also
always I've also always been fascinated
about the expansion of wakanda in
general you know because we've seen so
much of it happening in wakanda the
original movie this one taking place uh
wakanda forever in wakanda obviously
Infinity War the battle takes place
there I've been dying to see what does
the expansion of those open borders look
like more of that but also maybe open
borders to space so well I mean yes
there's president there has no borders
that's right
I mean it's such a great question and
theory in general because yeah I mean
The Intergalactic Empire of wakanda is
one of the more exciting things to
happen in the in the wakan in comics in
a while um
we're heading there at some point we've
got to yes I've been wanting it for so
long I'm like that that run was so much
fun I'm like let's go to space let's go
to space please but yes totally uh we
gotta go there eventually uh to Tyler
Junior please
um do your homework so you you're asking
go to space stay hard and get into get
into a good space program go to school
right go to school do your Haitian
homework test
before you do make sure you can handle
the harsh conditions exactly but up next
we're going to talk about Whitney's
amazing theory about how uh nebula got
this Bucky arm how did it happen maybe
sometimes you with the bucket I don't
know
be sure to check out the
rockstarsmerch.com where you can check
out our latest new rockstars merch and
still grab our forever King latest
Obsession shirt inspired by black
panther wakanda forever so you can
support the channel and check out all of
our awesome merch available at new
rockstarsmerch.com and we also want to
thank pharity for sponsoring this video
Verity is a family brand founded by Alex
his wife Carrie and his twin brother
Mike that channels their love of the
beach lifestyle into clothing for Life's
greatest moments parody is passionate
about craftsmanship comfort and
sustainability their ongoing partnership
with Native designers supports native
communities while helping and
appropriation in fashion every piece is
designed to be a lifetime favorite and
if anything happens along the way Verity
will replace or fix your clothes for
life no matter what that is the farody
promise layer up this winter with their
best-selling Legend sweater shirts for
men women and kids recycled High pile
fleece jackets and new Frost sweaters
producer Brandon loves his Verity shirts
he wore them this year to Thanksgiving
so that he would be comfy at the dinner
table while still looking sharp for all
the family photos Verity is giving all
Rogue Theory fans an amazing deal 20 off
your first order so head to
veritybrand.com Rogue Theory and use
code Rogue Theory at checkout to get
this amazing deal that's code Rogue
Theory at Verity
f-a-h-e-r-t-ybrand.com Rogue theory for
20 off veritybrand.com Rogue Theory also
we want to thank miraclebrandt for
sponsoring this video as well because
did you know that your temperature at
night can have one of the greatest
impacts on your sleeve quality if you
wake up too hot or too cold I highly
recommend you check out Miracle Brands
bed sheets inspired by silver infused
Fabrics made by NASA the space people
Miracle brand makes temperature
regulating bedding so that you can sleep
at the perfect temperature all night
these sheets are infused with natural
silver that prevent 99.9 of bacterial
growth leaving them to stay cleaner and
fresh three times longer than any other
sheet clean sheets means less bacteria
to clog your pores and fewer breakouts
and other skin problems Miracle sheets
are luxuriously comfortable without the
high price tag of other luxury Brands so
go to try miracle.com Rogue to try it
today or gift it to someone special this
holiday season
um save over 40 and be sure to use our
promo code Rogue at checkout to save
even more and get three free towels
three free towels three more towels than
you had before the extra drive this
holiday season and Miracle is so
confident in their products it's backed
with a 30 day money back guarantee so if
you aren't 100 satisfied you'll get a
free refund and you can upgrade your
sleep with Miracle brand today so go to
try miracle.com Rogue and use the code
Rogue to claim your free three-piece
towel set and save over 40 off again
that is try america.com Rogue to treat
yourself a friend or a loved one over
this holiday season and thank you again
to miraclebrand for sponsoring this
episode now it is time for Whitney to
bring us a second room so here we go wow
you guys let's get it just wow listen I
know that this is what we all want to
talk about this is all what we're dying
to talk about
how
how the heck did the arm end up in
nebula's possession did she go to his
house and rip it out of his body or or
maybe just maybe
what if
they got into the holiday spirit and
when I say they got into the holiday
spirit I mean like Lifetime movie Love
Actually
falling in love standing outside each
other's doorsteps with little sizes say
you are perfect to me what if
you know nebula shows up she's never
been to to Hollywood before she was
there you know same time as the other
Guardians were running around doing
their thing that's when she found the
opportunity she was like I'm just gonna
explore you guys do your thing so she
finds Bucky right they go I I've just
decided he's visiting L.A at this time
okay uh it's it's for the holidays and
he's just in town so they right they
meet she realizes perfect present for
Rocket they start to fight they're
fighting they're they're duking it out
but they realize that they're so equally
matched they're just gonna be locked in
this unending duel forever and it's
never gonna get any better and so
Bucky's like hey do you want to go see
the tree lighting at the Grove and she's
like yeah why not and so they go it's
magical it's beautiful it's romantic
they have a couple of cocktails and they
realize that Sparks are beginning to fly
and so they go back home some clothes
come off maybe some cyber lit cybernetic
limbs come off too and so what I'm
trying to say is what Brandon said so
much better than I ever could when I was
pitching him and empty this topic this
morning which is
Bucky put his heart on his sleeve nebula
just took it
[Laughter]
off screen poem producer Brandon Barrick
I love this so much I love this so so so
so much like I can see it happening
because they are basically sort of the
same in their own way I was thinking
that
um cybernetic people grumpy traumatized
half machines look at them what more
could you ask for for a holiday rom-com
like I feel like Marvel shouldn't have
their own like uh parody of Ninja
Turtles and like traumatize or whatever
you just said
like they're both hot like like they're
you know they're not both young because
Bucky's a billion years old but that's
okay they look young and they could fall
in love and like and like listen I'm not
talking about like any like sleazy
sleazy gross perfect I'm talking about
women with machine body parts take an
autonomy and and doing what pleases them
and I'm talking about men with body
parts of vibranium pleasing that woman
and it's a beautiful thing and it's a
beautiful time and I just think that
there's nothing more pure than the love
between Bucky and an alien I just think
that that could happen I feel like
She-Hulk paved the way she really did
banging Matt murder dude exactly yeah I
think like all these uh Marvel women
deserve to uh to bang the man of their
dreams really uh and Bucky's so hot like
I'm sorry he looks like a young Mark
Hamill like give him to me it's true
come on
so why does the end of this Lifetime
movie end with her then taking the Army
oh because uh she got his package and he
was like let me send you home with a
package to take to your friends and so
wow the constellation oh it was like it
was like a little like he was like this
is really important to your friend I can
tell and I respect that and Merry
Christmas from me to you here's the arm
I can get another one we're good
but that's why I think that the
wakandans are gonna be pissed at him
because they're gonna be like bro you
gave your [ __ ] arm to a girl you like
a little bit that's not cool and that's
why I think that then he's gonna say I
already have a rock hard arm
pretty good thank you very much
this episode is sponsored by buckchoo
right get as hard as vibrania
getting into Info Wars territory
um
how old do we think nebula is I don't
think I've ever considered this
wow that is a good question
um well how much of her is left to have
an age
Hmm this is true or just the age of the
equipment I guess hypothesia situation
yeah a real trip at thesis
that's a really good question because
like theoretically she could be as old
as Thanos because like she could have
been picked up first though I think
maybe Gamora was picked up first I don't
know what's official but yeah no like
she if she's just basically cybernetic
parts and we know from Iron Man that
like if you have cyber parts that can
sort of like run your body for for as
many lifetimes as needed maybe her and
Bucky are the same age so yeah okay so
let's just say yes I'm changing my mind
they are the same age and that's why
it's perfect because even if he tries to
date Sam's sister she's like way too
young for him dude and like maybe
nebulous the same age and like listen I
I really support that ship so I'm kind
of contradicting my true feelings here
because I do support from crushing on
Sam's sister really hard but what if
this Beautiful Romance happens first
what if what if
also this same age maybe it's just the
he just it gets him back into the swing
of things you know like it's not a
long-term thing but just you know you
gotta it takes it takes a bit it's not a
long term but it's like the card for a
spin every once in a while yeah you
gotta you gotta dust off those robot
Parts every once in a while you can't
just leave them locked up in the factory
he can't oh exactly and like at the very
least they can have like a casual fling
because like they're both soldiers and
they're both like you know they're
almost gone through it she's just like
hey and they deserve fun and love and
romance and everything on Earth is new
to nebula right she's experiencing all
of it for the first time so you're right
the emotions are heightened the
Christmas season
too ever seen a real penis before maybe
she's ever seen a human man's genitalia
maybe she's only seen aliens and we
don't know maybe this was like really
cool and exciting for her she's probably
like hey let me see what her ego was so
uh hyped up yeah
what's so special about her I really do
love this a lot as a theory like it's
just though I though personally I
personally ship nebula with Valkyrie
because I think they'll be that would
also be really cute and cool listen
bisexuals are free they can be with
anyone they can we can have all we can
have it all empty we don't have to pick
and choose exactly we can see the Bucky
we can get with Valkyrie we can do
whatever we want here man we are the
emcee
do you think there's there's any chance
of a of a trade could they have traded
cybernetic limbs what is nebula given me
what has nebula given him I mean this is
true who knows that's the other question
who knows exactly that is a very good
follow-up question well maybe like he he
traded uh the hand for uh the other hand
it's only fair thank you he was like Hey
if you give me a [ __ ] I will give you
my entire arm right you literally took
the soul out of my body so so here you
go take it I don't need this literally
took the soul out of my body literally
the ectoplasm left my body
um my God
okay what do we think about this theory
of uh Bucky
um doing the
um with a nebula to and like giving the
arm afterwards like do you guys think
it's rogus bogus or August I'm gonna
give it a double rope this way I just I
hope that that's Canon gets laid let's
do it is totally possible
I'm gonna go double rogus on this one as
well this is one where well the more the
more I think on it the more I really I
like what Mt was saying about the you
know their shared experiences and how
like beyond the fact they are both
people made up largely of of non-organic
material
they also have both had their brains
kind of scrambled they've both been sort
of made to serve people and causes that
they didn't necessarily believe in or
agree with and so right exactly oh
that's a good point I like you know now
they're having to put the pieces
together figure out who they are yeah
all those things would make you so horny
if you found those qualities in another
person you'd just be horny for it I'm
sorry I I honestly don't think that like
nebula had it like all that much time to
like release that
um tension while serving Thanos yeah
they don't suck she deserves a little
fun out on the town she's a strong lady
I support her right right yeah Thanos
not good and like let's let's be real um
if I heard that like someone's dad was
Thanos I'm not oh yeah I'm not trying to
I'm not trying to eat that [ __ ] I'm
staying far away right enjoy those
drinks have a nice night Bucky's not
making this happen until Thanos is off
he's like phew
um so yeah no this is like a rogus all
around thank you with me like you are so
excited you guys this is my first time
that I've ever picked I've ever
presented a rogue Theory did you know
that this is my first my first time yes
I'm so excited one for one yeah
but now it is time for our Rogue
question are you guys ready for this
hold on yes maybe because the first
trailer for Transformers rise of the
Beast dropped this week and it doesn't
have Haley Seinfeld in it so I will not
be watching just kidding
um
I'm only 75 kidding all right for but
for today's real question if you are a
Transformer what would be the thing that
you would want to transform into Bucky's
arm done yeah
and you're just gonna chill with rocket
now I guess can I transform into the
mech that rocket makes out of all of the
limbs the that Mt told us about earlier
yes
that'd be a crazy time I'm just gonna
transform into nebula she's basically a
robot right
do it do it then you can [ __ ] you with
the Bucky I thought Kyle would go for
the uh an Iron Man suit oh
that's a good call that'd be balling
yeah that would be freaking ball
yeah okay I'd want to transform into a
PlayStation 5 console I don't know why
like I want to transform into something
stupid like a Nintendo 64. I'm like yay
I'm so full of games and fun
exactly and you sit there forever and
let people play I feel like the like uh
the FBI or the CIA would want to hire me
if they knew that I could transform it
to Nintendo 64 because I could just go
undercover you could go undercover every
frat house crime you would solve because
you'd be undercover fly on the wall
exactly uh I'm picturing like a secret
bunker like the sort of place where you
would need like a really covert agent in
and there's just an n64.
hey who wants my Super Mario Bros over
here
you know that scene that scene in The
Matrix where like uh carrion Moss is
like hacking and like the guys come in
and it's like hey and she's like alone
in there hacking instead it's just her
alone and they're playing in n64.
little trench coat she's just like this
is actually great
right in the middle of the water temple
from Ocarina of Time you pop back out
right you know what I'm busy like she's
like she's busy we should probably leave
it looks like she needs to really beat
this level she's focused
wait did you go Whitney no
no I just said Bucky's arm I'm sticking
without okay I would transform into
Bucky's arm and then I'll be part of the
mech suit that Robbie evolves into
that's true we can work together that's
beautiful it's a Whitney Robbie team up
friends from work wow friends from work
yes look at us
I'm going to give the Rogue question
trophy to the the Bucky machine yeah I
mean yeah the Bucky our machine
wants to be really crazy Teamwork Makes
the DreamWorks I think we all went for
that yeah she's like friends from work
let's we'll all contributed
exactly let's all contributing arm will
all be a different part of this mech
suit and then Rocky can drive us all
around and we'll all just be like it's
so nice so we're friends and hanging out
guys it would be great oh my God oh my
God will look like one of Sid's toys
but that is it for this episode of Rogue
Theory thanks as always to Whitney van
luntingham and a huge thanks to the
friends from work uh Kyle's going to
Will and Robbie Earl for joining us
today you guys are amazing super funny
and I just really great guys make sure
to check out their podcast friends from
work you can find them on all sorts or
platforms at the ffw podcast or the
ffwpodcast.com and you can support our
Channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch over at New
rockstarsmerch.com you can follow me at
Master retainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] you can follow new
rockstars and all social platforms and
be sure to subscribe to our channel here
on YouTube we love you guys so much
thank you guys for spending time with us
and we'll see you guys next time goodbye
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]